je pense qu'il faut pas tous les mettre
dans le même panier
on vous écoute je pensais à la typologie
de l'impôt sur la fortune isf moment du
passage édifie et à l'époque lorsqu'on
regarde et on s'apercevait que il y
avait déjà une première catégorie de
contribuables étaient riches qui avait
un patrimoine compris entre 1 millions
3,2 millions 4 mais c'était 70% des
redevables de l isf et pour eux à 80%
leur patrimoine c'est d'immobilier
principalement leur résidence principale
et puis pour les 30 % qui restent là on
parle on commence à parler de gens très
riches et à dire faire l'échelle
française c'est à dire des gens qui ont
un patrimoine d'une valeur nette
supérieure à 10 millions 4 et plus vous
êtes fortunés plus corrélativement et ça
semble a priori assez logique plus la
proportion de l'immobilier dans votre
patrimoine diminue alors le problème
c'est que on se retrouve avec ses
contribuables qui ont entre 1 million 3
et 2 millions 4 et qui sont avec leur
résidence principale qui surtout à paris
vous l'évoquiez tout à l'heure où on
arrive vite à des montants considérables
pour des appartements et puis on a ces
30% qui sont des contribuables très
fortunés mais la particularité ces
contribuables ac qui vivent dans un
monde ouvert contrairement aux autres et
lorsqu'on vit dans un monde ouvert c'est
pas compliqué de passer quelques mois en
france quelques mois en belgique et puis
vous voulez donc ces contribuables très
fortunés généralement arrive grâce à ce
qu'on appelle le frob shopping bag
shopping a échappé quand même en grande
partie
à beaucoup d'imposition
[Musique]